I'm still shocked and really sad that
he's not around anymore legendary singer
Prince died at 57 on Thursday and the
music community is completely devastated
I can't really accept it right now it
just happened so I'm I'm kind of
wrapping my head around it et was with
the voice coaches on Thursday in LA
where they got personal about the iconic
artists and how his legacy impacted them
as people and musicians he was just
fearless and did things his way and I
always wanted to do things my way and
people who inspired me to do that among
the few were friends was probably top of
the list he'll never be another Prince
many kings queens and princesses but
there will never be another Prince his
music his message his movement the way
he moved like he was just there's only
one him he just had an impact on the
world you know not just music you know
that's what hurts i think the most is i
feel like we lost almost like a
superhero today his music is just
timeless and just you know so authentic
and so genuine just a monster talent
will always be remembered
you